Yeah,
I have no idea.
No particular event comes to my mind or
whatever.
It's certainly true that in the post
World War Two era when I was.
I was born in 1939,
so you can do the math,
excuse me.
Lots of stuff was happening in,
in,
in New York City.
The United Nations was being built.
Lever House was being built.
I remember seeing lever has when it was
nearing completion for the first time
because my dentist office was down the
block,
so to speak,
things that you could see at the museum
of Modern Art,
the various houses that were built in
the garden.
I went to all of them with my parents.
Took me to the and so let's say
subliminally that interested me.
I did have a teacher in a junior high
school and she was the art teacher or an
art teacher and her brother was a city
planner and when I expressed my
interests,
I suppose he.
She connected me to the brother who was
living in Cleveland as I recall.
So it was just the fact that there was
somebody out there might be interested
in what I was doing,
making little drawings.